[Música]
Hola Esto es África 7 días el magazine
donde les presentamos la actualidad del
continente africano yo soy Santiago
López González por mi compañera
amalvenotman y estos son los temas del
programa de hoy
comenzamos esta edición en la región de
los grandes lagos el gobierno de la
República democrática del Congo acusó a
Ruanda de apoyar el m-23 un grupo armado
que tomó el control de varias ciudades
en el este del país en respuesta el
gobierno concolés expulsó al embajador
ruandés los detalles en tan solo unos
momentos
iremos también a Sudán donde el pasado
25 de octubre marcó el primer
aniversario del golpe de estado que puso
fin a la transición democrática en ese
país un año después los militares no
muestran la intención de querer ceder el
poder mientras el país está sumido en la
confusión política y en una profunda
crisis económica vamos a analizar la
situación con Ricardo Benítez director
del observatorio África en el centro de
investigación política Internacional de
la Universidad de Buenos Aires en
Argentina
y terminaremos en Avi ya en la capital
económica de Costa de Marfil en donde
conoceremos a una mujer que trabaja
desde hace 10 años con menores de edad y
jóvenes de la calle que han caído en la
delincuencia y que buscan una nueva
oportunidad para salir adelante
empezamos en la República democrática
del Congo mientras el grupo armado m23
Avanza en el este del país las
acusaciones se dirigen a la vecina
Ruanda país que es culpado de financiar
y suministrar armas a ese grupo
insurgente en la ciudad de goma donde
hay cerca algunas posiciones del m-23
los ciudadanos protagonizaron
manifestaciones en donde quemaron
banderas holandesas y también gritaron
consignas y reclamos contra el gobierno
de
estos manifestantes están decididos
quieren ser vistos y escuchados por eso
se reunieron para gritar su Furia contra
el país vecino Ruanda con pancartas y
demás hostiles al régimen de kigali
también quemaron la bandera rusa en las
barreras del puesto fronterizo cerca de
la ciudad de goma
vamos a salvarnos a nosotros mismos ya
hemos tenido lo suficiente el pueblo se
va a liberar sabemos que quizás hayamos
firmado nuestra sentencia de muerte ya
que vivimos con Los espías del m-23 en
la ciudad pero a quién le importa si eso
significa morir por el interés nacional
nuestro país o la muerte venceremos la
toma de las ciudades de sants y kiwancha
por parte del m23 dio lugar a una
reunión del Consejo superior de defensa
en quinchaza la capital de la República
democrática del Congo una de las
conclusiones del encuentro fue la
expulsión del embajador de Ruanda dicen
carega le pasó es superior de la el
consejo superior de defensa Pide al
gobierno que expulse en las 48 horas
siguientes al Señor Vincent carega
embajador de Ruanda en la República
democrática del Congo caiga ambas Esto
se debe por un lado a la persistente
agresión de Ruanda contra la República
democrática del Congo y a su apoyo al
movimiento terrorista m23 que utiliza
para este fin por otro lado a la
arrogante desprecio de las autoridades
por los procesos de nairobi y luanda y
la recomendaciones de la comunidad
internacional
la respuesta del gobierno Irlandés no
tardó en llegar
es lamentable que el gobierno de la
República democrática del Congo sigue
utilizando a Ruanda como culpable para
encubrir y desviar la atención de sus
fallos de gobernanza y de seguridad
Mientras tanto en el este de la
República democrática del Congo los
desplazados por los combates siguen
llegando a campamentos improvisados en
el norte de la ciudad de goma el consejo
de seguridad de la República democrática
del Congo ha pedido al gobierno que
envíe una misión humanitaria urgente
ante estas acusaciones y manifestaciones
la unión africana expresó su
preocupación por la atención en la
República democrática del Congo al
tiempo que pidió también un alto el
fuego inmediato entre tanto el gobierno
Irlandés negó ese supuesto apoyo que le
da al m-23 y a su vez acusó al gobierno
con goles de apoyar a las fuerzas
democráticas de liberación de Ruanda que
es un grupo armado utu que estuvo
implicado en el genocidio de 1994
pasamos ahora a Sudán un año después del
golpe de estado perpetrado por el
ejército que sumió a este país en la
confusión política miles de
manifestantes volvieron a marchar para
rechazar el gobierno militar y exigir
una transición a un gobierno civil
recordemos que el general Alborán jefe
del ejército rompió su compromiso de
compartir el poder con los dirigentes
civiles a los que hizo detener la
madrugada del 25 de octubre del 2021
desde entonces los manifestantes y
también los activistas piden una
transición a un gobierno civil y repiten
la misma Consigna ninguna negociación ni
asociación con los golpistas
para analizar la situación política en
Sudán nos acompaña Ricardo Benítez Él es
director del observatorio África en el
centro de investigación de política
Internacional de la Universidad de
Buenos Aires en Argentina señor Benítez
Gracias por estar con nosotros y con el
escenario actual el nivel de político
allí en Sudán está incrementándose la
atención cómo está entonces la sociedad
sudanesa frente a la situación política
que se está viviendo allí está unida o
está dividida en un rechazo como un para
los militares creo que desde un punto de
vista de la sociología sería muy difícil
definir que hay una en millones de
personas unidas en un en un mismo ideal
porque claramente siempre suele haber
divisiones si es lógico que lo que es
las las protestas sociales Si se
encuentran bien concentradas en los
reclamos de algunas organizaciones que
escuchamos muy bien como la asociación
sudanesa de profesionales o incluso las
fuerzas por la libertad y el cambio que
son los que motorizan este tipo de
protestas claramente al interior deben
haber algunos debates respecto Por
ejemplo si se puede negociar con los
militares nuevamente Si hay que cambiar
esos términos de negociación o si no de
haber ningún tipo de negociación la
unión africana y Naciones Unidas están
justamente tratando de mediar entre
ambas partes pero el grado de
radicalización entre las posturas más
más extremas tanto del sector civil como
del sector militar hace que ese tipo de
mediación sea mucho más difícil A
diferencia de la que la luna Unión
africana hace dos años atrás por lo
tanto
no diría que que habría una unidad en
tanto y en cuanto puede haber distintas
matices sobre cómo hacer para
resolver el impass político en el que se
encuentra asociado hoy día señor Benítez
porque los militares de Sudán siguen
aferrándose al poder sin dar ningún tipo
de muestra de que ver hacer esta
transición hacia un gobierno civil a que
le temen
una característica que ha tenido el
estado sudanesa a lo largo de su
historia es de que no no se conformó
como una entidad Estatal dispuesta a
satisfacer demandas sociales a lo largo
de la historia todo tipo de demanda
Empezando por Sudán del sur
posteriormente por darfur Córdoba azul
representó una idea donde el gobierno el
gobierno central directamente coercionó
cualquier tipo de resistencia eso
permitió una militarización muy fuerte
de de la relación de las demandas
sociales con el estado tales Así que la
concentración autocrática del Estado ha
sido Prácticamente la Norma y no la
excepción ante la salida del Valle lo
que se nota es que el sector militar de
alguna manera no no busco perder esas
prerrogativas sino liderar el sistema de
transición quizás como para que cambie
todo y no cambia nada al mismo tiempo
como se suele decir claramente en el
contexto posmoderno y de las primaveras
aves que se habían visualizado
previamente quizás la potencialidad de
la sociedad civil de poder alcanzar el
poder y posteriormente esta
circunstancia donde los militares
vuelven a retomar poder sin permitir a
los civiles participar es lo que de
alguna manera ha generado esta esta
mayor resistencia por parte de la
sociedad civil era su oportunidad y la
encía la la tendrían obstaculizada de
momento señor Benítez con la
independencia de Sudán del sur el
ejército sudanés perdió prácticamente su
única fuente de financiación que era el
petróleo entonces sin este recurso cómo
se financian cómo se mantienen en el
poder a pesar de esa falta de
legitimidad que tienen ante la población
una de las cosas que se está hablando de
una de los elementos que hizo la salida
del Valle fue también la crisis la
crisis económica una crisis vinculada
también por el problema de desarrollo
institucional y eventualmente por por la
inflación y Los costos alimenticios algo
que se potencia hoy día también con la
guerra de Rusia y Ucrania y también con
la con la inflación posterior a la
pandemia de Kobe 19 ahora bien
lo si bien ellos Perdieron el control de
las rentas petroleras todavía el sistema
de infraestructuras de la región hace
que su banda del sur tenga los recursos
pero que esto se tengan que refinar y
exportar a través de Sudán del Norte y
eso también ha generado distintos
conflictos con los gobiernos de Sudán
del sur que todavía no se encuentran
conformados como como estado por otro
lado el aumento de los impuestos y una
política más regresiva en términos en
términos impositivos lo que lo que
estaría generando es una especie de
estado más cleptocrático decir un estado
que se autofinancia o por lo menos una
ley política que se autofinancia a
través de la extracción de recursos de
la misma sociedad lo cual también al
mismo tiempo dificulta impotencia el
grado de radicalización también de las
protestas sociales dado que cada vez
sufre más el poder político pero no
tiene ningún tipo de acceso o a
contability para poder cambiar esa
situación señor Benítez Muchas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros aquí en
África siete días pasemos ahora a
somalia este país del cuerno de África
ha sufrido su peor ataque desde el año
2017 así lo han calificado por lo menos
las autoridades de ese país más de 100
personas murieron en un doble atentado
con coche bomba ocurrido el pasado 29 de
octubre los hechos ocurrieron en la
capital la ciudad de mogadillo las
autoridades somalíes también informaron
que otras 300 personas resultaron
heridas la explosión se produjo en una
concurrida vía de la capital tras un
primer estallido las personas que
estaban en la zona y los equipos de
rescate que llegaron hasta allí para
atender la emergencia Fueron
sorprendidos por una segunda detonación
las autoridades somalíes atribuyeron de
acuerdo a las características que
contenido del ataque a una incursión de
los militantes del grupo alzabab este
grupo yihadista lleva desde el 2007
luchando contra el Gobierno Federal
somalí fue expulsado de las principales
ciudades incluida mogadillo la capital
en el 2011 Pero sigue firmemente
arraigado principalmente en algunas
zonas Rurales del Sur del país
y vamos a cambiar de tema nos vamos
ahora hasta Avilán la capital económica
de Costa de Marfil allí en el popular
barrio de abobo vive en masaje quise
desde hace 10 años la madre como es
conocida y entre los residentes se ocupa
de los menores y de los jóvenes que
habitan en la calle y que han caído en
la delincuencia y quienes a nivel local
son conocidos despectivamente Como
microbios está su historia
más son 16 lleva 10 años cuidando a
estos menores a menudo huérfanos
los que tienen comportamientos agresivos
reciben el nombre de microbios Pero
recuerda que se trata de niños que deben
ser protegidos
Por esto estoy luchando para que se deje
de llamarlos así
son seres humanos estos niños dejaron la
escuela a una edad muy temprana y andan
por ahí fuera
les ayudamos mañana pueden llegar a
hacer algo
en su Modesto salón más allá coge a una
quincena de niños para alimentarlos solo
cuenta con el salario de su marido un
comerciante le gustaría tener los medios
que se necesitan y el apoyo de las
autoridades para hacer aún más
hoy me gustaría tener un lugar para
llevar a todos estos niños tengo muchos
hijos pero no tengo un lugar donde
llevarlos
quiero trabajar pero necesito una
estructura
todo el mundo la conoce porque es en
este barrio del norte de la capital
económica donde hay más niños
abandonados a su suerte
el número se ha disparado desde la
crisis política de 2011 en Costa de
Marfil para luchar contra la precariedad
del barrio más andé ayuda a los de mayor
edad a entrar en la vida profesional es
el caso de estos jóvenes sastres que
ahora trabajan en este taller
Hace cuatro años conocí a mamá tenía
problemas en la calle y no sabía qué
hacer ahora vivo correctamente como un
hombre responsable y ayudo un poco de mi
familia gracias
una treintena de niños en la calle se
han convertido ensastres peluqueros o
trabajadores domésticos para ella
proporcionar un entorno estable a estos
niños de la calle es la manera como
Costa de Marfil podría erradicar el
fenómeno de la delincuencia juvenil
y así termina la edición de esta semana
de África 7 días gracias por su sintonía
recuerde más información en France
24.com y en nuestra programación Hasta
pronto
[Música]